wir verurteilen das ganze wir werden
angemessen reagieren wir hoffen dass
russland da jetzt aufklärung betreibt es
ist irgendwie immer dasselbe bringt das
in dem fall überhaupt irgendwas ja so
auf der einen seite hast du recht das
ist ein mann denkt ist es eine
gebrochene schallplatte nach jedem neuen
schlimmen angriff oder nach jedem baby
on the right ist vorhin gesagt hat wir
kennen das seit der ukraine dass man da
so sich zurücknehmen muss die seite seit
monaten krankenhäusern in syrien so
anders nur sagen was sollen die beiden
machen ja also es ist ja nun jetzt
schwierig und man kann jetzt nicht die
gleiche große keule rausholen wie
russland sich rausholt werden ihnen
etwas nicht gefällt und jetzt mit dem
völkerrecht vorbei jetzt irgendein
strafmaßnahmen aussprechen insofern ist
es tatsächlich schwierig in der
situation die sich dort befinden und
besonders schwierig finde ich immer
diese forderung der aufklärung also mann
mann mann fordert jetzt jemand auf
aufzuklären von dem man relativ sicher
ist dass er dafür verantwortlich ist
denn wir haben es von peter helfer und
gehört nur wie talk wird nicht in einem
keller hergestellt sondern in einem
militärischen labor
insofern ist davon auszugehen wenn
dieser tisch kampfstoff in russland
eingesetzt wurde gegen jemand dass auch
die russische führung das russische
militär dort mit zu tun hat und die
werden natürlich ein teufel tun sich
jetzt selbst aufzuklären und am ende
dann zu sagen ja tatsächlich wir haben
herausgefunden wie haben das zeug
hergestellt und jemand von unseren
agenten hat ihn gegeben insofern ist das
eine schwierige sache natürlich
nichtsdestotrotz was sie jetzt machen
können und das haben sie auch gesagt ist
dass man eine gemeinsame antwort sich
überlegt diese antwort habe er auch
schon gehört kann nur innerhalb der
europäischen union wir haben auch in dem
statement heute abend regen wird
innerhalb der nato gefunden werden das
ist natürlich keine militärische antwort
oder ähnliches aber ich denke dass wenn
man ist tatsächlich ernst meint mit
russland dann kann man solche sanktionen
personengebundene sanktionen auch finden
die wirklich weh tun und dabei gibt es
dann nicht um irgendeinen oberste und
einer militärbasis der irgendwo der noch
nie in europa war sondern dabei muss es
natürlich um das umfeld von herrn putin
gehen um diese olli gagen um milliardäre
die selbst in europa deren kinder in
europa die ganze zeit leben urlaub
machen studieren und so weiter und sich
davon überhaupt nicht stören lassen dass
da irgendein kleiner soldat irgendwie
mal sanktioniert wird wegen einem
abschluss eines flugzeuges ma 17 ich
erinnere daran oder ähnliches sondern
das wurde tatsächlich wie tun wenn man
dort in die russische führung und in die
menschen die von putin abhängig sind
aber von denen auch putin abhängig ist
also wenn es den nicht mehr gut geht und
wenn ihre kinder nicht mehr in europa
studieren können dann möchte ich mal
sehen wie lange die noch putin
freundlich sind und wann jedoch anfangen
zu sagen er lieber herr präsident wir
sollten wir so außenpolitik ändern weil
sonst haben wir nämlich in der familie
trouble